((Intro))
*pop*
There's a common misconception that depression
is easy to spot. Hollywood often depicts it as
somebody who is always sad or looks worn out.
But, depression isn't always
obvious, which is why so many of us struggle with it
silently.
Sometimes, even smiling on the outside
when we're really dying on the inside.
Here are 5 hidden signs of depression.
1) You have habitual remedies.
Therapy and medication can help with depression,
but if you find yourself making extra changes
to your lifestyle, then it can indicate that you're struggling more
than usual with it.
I'm going through this one myself. If you are too,
you may find yourself exercising more frequently,
listening to music more often, or doing your
favorite hobbies to distract yourself from the pain you're feeling.
Hidden depression exists when you're trying to
quiet the the loud demons in your head.
2) You have irregular eating and sleeping
patterns. People with depression struggle with
consistent sleeping and eating patterns
You may find you're either sleeping and eating too much,
or too little. Depression can work in extremes,
and slows us down when we get little
energy from our irregular daily patterns.
3) You're highly philosophical.
Do you constantly find yourself seeking a purpose in life?
Do you also think about the "What ifs",
and have frequent deep conversations about life and death?
Although you sound very scholarly and smart,
there can also be a downside to thinking too much.
People with hidden depression have a tendency to ruminate
about their uncertainties in life.
They usually feel directionless, lost,
and scared.
4) You have trouble with abandonment.
People with depression understand how much of a burden
it can be. I can strongly relate to this.
I have a hard time letting people in, afraid that
it'll be harder for them to be there for me when I
need their support.
I realize I have abandonment issues,
but I'm trying harder to be more vulnerable.
I realize I can't fight depression alone,
and neither should you. No one should have to.
5) You're losing your patience. Have you been
feeling irritable or angry with others lately?
Depression doesn't always have to look like sadness
or dejection. Instead, you might
find yourself frustrated and impatient with everyone.
If you feel like you're at your last straw, your
depression might have intensified.
Do you resonate with any of these hidden signs?
We want you to know that you're not alone, and together,
we can fight depression.
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Also, please don't forget to subscribe for more content
from Psych2Go, and share this video to get a free
copy of our magazine! With your help, we can reach
more people to spread awareness about
mental health issues. Thanks for your support!
Really and truly. We wouldn't have gotten this far
without each and every one of you. Have a good day!
Thanks for watching!
Hey everybody! I just wanted to give a personal thank you video for
you guys for always supporting Psych2Go
and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness, and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for you guys.
I would love your support in buying one of these bracelets from our partner,
IntrovertPalace. Check out the bracelet, it's pretty cool and
it even includes Pluto. The link to purchase will all be in the
description below, and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye!
((Outro))